[موسيقى]
شكرًا لك،
بعضًا من مخاريط التونة لدينا، ثم لدينا
نكهات مختلفة طوال الوقت مثل هذا
العام، لقد أتى طاهينا من شركة Cut London في وقت
مبكر وهو يعد لحم البقر ولنجتون
والسمك ورقائق البطاطس، ثم يقوم إريك هنا
بشواء  لحم بقري ميازاكي وبعض جراد البحر
المشوي، لذلك يكون هناك دائمًا
شيء مختلف ثم نقيم
بوفيهًا كبيرًا هناك مع جميع الحلويات،
لذلك نحصل على جميع الفواكه والخضروات
مباشرة من سوق المزارعين هنا
وأه نفس الشيء مع بعض الأسماك
هنا من  هناك جزر هناك، لذلك
كل شيء هو أفضل المكونات
[موسيقى]
نعلم أن توم كروز يحب
لحم بقر ميازاكي وباربرا سترايسند ومن المحتمل أنهم
يحبون فطائر وعاء الدجاج
نعم في يوم حفل توزيع جوائز الأوسكار،
ربما يكون لدينا 300 طاهٍ معًا
لدينا مطبخان كبيران، أحدهما هنا على
الجانب الآخر من قاعة الاحتفالات ولدينا
600 شخص في غرفة الطعام، لذا أه كما
تعلم أن النوادل لديهم صبية حافلات
وسقاة وكل شيء لأنه عندما
يخرج الناس من المسرح يكونون
جميعًا جائعين، كما تعلم  كل الأفلام
تبدأ بالرغبة في تناول الطعام الأجنبي على الفور
[موسيقى]